[Music]
whoa think it's time to let go
I think it's time to get low strike lost
egos time to let those whoa think it's
time to let show that show think the
time that they know to these guys too -
time that they glow I was boxed in how
many stunts grow for a minute - didn't
know when I was getting up funny times
when you're real down a few the times
you should be stepping on it well I
guess that's why lesson dad's never been
a stranger to a lesson cars for an FFL
cover in the heaven car wishing
everybody had the best of luck cuz me
I'm really about to ever up hopes bust
me had a not real [ __ ] living by my ho
hold it to me if I said it once for my
own and I get it done love [ __ ] and I
let him love rahu wish sandstone to find
words from your second son antenna good
go recession heart and
good God perception each detour show me
my direction each three boys from one
place read more like why I'm texting on
the seashore figured by my stress reform
a time for eggs if the loves ruled and
that's why I'm taking off I'm trying to
find ascension waking up lost trying to
find a friendship for IG man I can find
a mention I should grind wheat I'm
trying to find it [ __ ]
good soil for me to plan my roots branch
pro as I bought the truth cash coin is
not a part fruit used to coop they're
not a part of roof well well grow think
it's time to let go I think it's time to
get a little shrug off these goes time
to let those what thanks time to let
shove that show take your time that they
know you're these guys to manage time
that they glowing
[Music]
[Music]